on rejoint tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial sur place Caroline de Camaret
bonjour Caroline une conférence de
presse conjointe s'est tenue tout à
l'heure elle sera d'ailleurs diffusée
prochainement sur notre antenne
qu'est-ce qui en est ressorti alors
c'est vrai que vous savez les présidents
européens côté européen Charles Michel
et c'est la Vander Lee pour la
commission ainsi de sur l'aide
exceptionnelle plus de 60 milliards
d'euros débloqués pour l'Ukraine et la
volonté de d'aider de les aider à
poursuivre leur chemin d'intégration
dans l'Union européenne même s'il ne
donne pas de garantie que voudrait
obtenir pourtant le président zélinski
sur une adhésion qui qui serait
véritablement ouverte c'est-à-dire des
négociations démarrer des le mois de
septembre était le rapport donc de la
Commission de septembre octobre sur
l'état d'avancement de l'Ukraine il
voudrait voir son pays vient ouvrir les
35 chapitres de négociations et ça
évidemment ils disent tout de même les
deux à quel point l'Ukraine a fait des
efforts sur le chemin de l'Union
européenne et à quel point elle se
réforme en ce moment alors qu'on est en
pleine guerre et ça le président
rappelle toujours que on est en pleine
guerre que c'est un pays en guerre tout
de même et qu'est-ce qui est important
pour lui ce sont le à la fois les
soutiens financiers très importants mais
aussi le soutien par les sanctions les
sanctions pour la sur la défense ont
marché par exemple estiment-ils du point
de vue des Européens car les Russes
n'ont plus d'accès aux armements et il
est important que on fasse en sorte que
ces sanctions ne soient pas contournées
par d'autres pays pour donner des armes
il est très important cette question des
armements pour pour le président des a
inscrit qui a rappelé qu'on gagnait la
guerre avec des armes et que c'était
véritablement cela qui faisait la
différence c'est peut-être un peu pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il est s'est rendu à
Washington et non pas encore à Bruxelles
parce qu'effectivement les Américains
sont leaders en matière d'armement
de cette Ukraine en guerre alors il a
aussi souligné c'était assez intéressant
il soulignait en ce moment qu'il y a six
réacteurs nucléaires dans dans
le complexe de zapporica et que là la
Russie effectivement
détient la clé de ce complexe et
notamment rosatum qui est la vraie le
vrai dirigeant de cette centrale et
peut-être qu'il faut encore rajouter des
sanctions justement sur ces leaders
c'est ces leaders énergétiques russes
qui véritablement joue une part très
importante dans
l'accès ou non des Ukrainiens a de
l'énergie à l'électricité etc en tout
cas c'est vrai que la démonstration de
force de l'Union européenne hier avec
toute la commission enfin la moitié de
la commission qui est venue aujourd'hui
avec les trois présidents et le chef de
la diplomatie qui sont présents sur le
sol de Kiev et bien tout cela
à démontré que l'Ukraine fait d'ores et
déjà partie de la famille européenne
c'est ce qu'on voulait signifier en tout
cas les dirigeants européens elle en
fait partie et elle poursuit son chemin
vers nous malgré la guerre